well let's just bring you the latest
satellite imagery that we have received
now this is coming from maxar satellite
imagery uh they are a private u.s space
technology company and they have been uh
tracking the build-up of russian forces
for the last few weeks these images that
they have released appear to show
a very large deployment of russian
ground forces you can see lots and lots
of military vehicles there
hundreds of them in a convoy that now
this is apparently to the northeast
of the ukrainian city of ivankev
and moving in the direction of kiev
we understand that this position is
about 40 miles away which is about 64
kilometers away
and this convoy extends for more than
three miles in length about five
kilometers long
and from the images it's believed that
it's contained fuel logistics armored
vehicles
and it is traveling along the chev
chenker road moving towards ivankev
so they just reiterate these images have
come to us from maxar which is a a
private u.s space technology company
which has been monitoring the movement
of russian troops in ukraine other
satellite imagery that we've seen today
shows antonov airport in hostimel
and that has also shown the damage
caused by recent air strikes and heavy
fighting
in and around the airport there as well